si ya se conocen los primeros resultados
oficiales que apuntarían a una victoria
del rechazo como se había vaticinado en
este caso con un 45% el apruebo y un 55%
del rechazo en un primerísimo escrutinio
que se va a ir actualizando en las
próximas horas es también la sensación
que tenemos en este colegio electoral
que es de tendencia más bien progresista
donde también se siente bastante el voto
del rechazo y por lo que hemos estado
siguiendo en otros colegios electorales
esta tendencia se estaría imponiendo por
el momento ha sido una jornada electoral
histórica en el país con una alta
participación de ciudadanos la primera
vez que se restituye el voto obligatorio
desde 2012 según encuestas que no son
fiables pero por lo que podíamos ver en
mesas de votación en las que
participaban 300 320 personas de 400
estaríamos hablando de una participación
bastante alta 75 en una participación
histórica en un país como chile en el
que tradicionalmente
en las elecciones no participa ni un 50
del electorado con voto obligatorio con
voto voluntario por ejemplo las últimas
elecciones en las que salió presidente
de gabriel boric suero en las elecciones
con mayor rango de votación llega un 53
por ciento una ciudad una jornada muy
democrática muy bien el espíritu chileno
un país con grandes tradiciones
republicanas donde todo el mundo acude a
ejercer el voto de manera pacífica donde
hay instancias para hacer reclamos donde
hay observadores de ambos de ambas
posturas donde también el servicio
electoral es muy respetado ese mismo que
anuncia con bastante celeridad los
resultados y donde hemos visto largas
filas pero también un voto muy expedito
puesto que la opción estaba aclarado
ahora lo que
tenemos que ver cómo evolucionan estas
primeras votos si bien el voto en el
extranjero se había manifestado a favor
de la prueba como suele ser también
tradición por el momento el rechazo va
avanzando en los resultados y de ahí qué
es lo que sucederá a partir de mañana en
el país es una incógnita ante la que
estamos sin lugar a dudas patricia bueno
hablabas de un alto nivel de
participación y esto seguramente no
claramente estará vinculado a qué son es
obligatorio ir a votar en estos comicios
algo que no es tradición en chile-
hablabas también del clima que se vivió
hasta el momento contarnos un poco de
los crímenes clima de estos días previos
no se han visto campañas movilizaciones
un chile polarizado ciertamente
así es un chile muy polarizado en el que
ha reinado la incertidumbre en este
proceso histórico sobre si finalmente se
va a enterrar la constitución de la
dictadura o no va a ser así las
encuestas daban siempre como favoritos
al rechazo está la gran sensación que se
diría sin embargo en el cierre de
campaña del jueves vimos cómo los
partidarios de la prueba salían
masivamente a las calles a celebrar su
acción a manifestar su acción y eso dio
como una esperanza de que quizá estas
las encuestas se podían equivocar como
se han equivocado en otras ocasiones en
el país el gran tema es cuántos la gran
incógnita siempre ha sido cuántas nuevas
personas que no han votado mucho tiempo
acudieron allí a votar y de qué forma lo
han hecho también es verdad que se ha
puesto mucho esfuerzo tanto por parte
del gobierno por promover la
participación como por parte del
servicio electoral por ejemplo cambiando
la geolocalización de los votar de los
locales electorales de forma que cada
chileno tenga el local de votación más
cerca de su casa muchos de ellos nos
superaban los 15 minutos de
algo que es completamente nuevo antes
por ejemplo
yo que como ciudadana extranjera puede
votar tenía que trasladarme hasta una
hora caminando al lugar de votación y
ahora se ha hecho eso es mucho más
sencillo también se ha enviado en
mensajes de texto para que todo el mundo
participara el ambiente como tú bien
decías estaba muy reñido en las calles
cuando uno salía a reportear o bien a
grabar
o hacer cualquier tipo de tema siempre
pasaban personas que se mostraban a
favor de la propiedad en personas que se
manifestaban a favor del rechazo
son muchas las incógnitas que se abren
en este proceso que va a seguir
continuando no termina este 4 de
septiembre sino que se inicia un nuevo
ciclo para muchos este este ciclo que
partió con la revuelta de octubre de
2019 y que se manifestó en el plebiscito
de entrada en el 80 por ciento de los
chilenos manifestaron su deseo de acabar
con la constitución que rige la
actualidad y hacerlo a través de un
proceso una convención constituyente en
este ciclo va a continuar puesto que la
necesidad de cambios expresó las que
hayáis expresado en diversas formas sin
embargo es verdad que el proceso de la
elaboración de este texto constitucional
ha estado lleno de polémicas y también
que quizá no se siempre se ha sabido
comunicar de mejor forma en los
contenidos del nuevo texto
constitucional que el debate ha estado
más en él texto de cómo se produjo la
redacción de esa constitución más que en
el texto mismo y eso es lo que uno
sentía también en las calles un debate
sobre qué es lo que se está votando que
realmente se está votando sobre el texto
constitucional se está votando sobre el
proceso se está votando como un castigo
al gobierno porque el gobierno se mostró
favorable a la prueba y mucha gente
entiende el voto en la actualidad como
un voto de castigo un voto de
del rechazo un poco a las propuestas del
gobierno que entró con altas
expectativas y que bajo
está teniendo una de las peores índices
de popularidad de la historia de la
democracia son muchísimos los factores
que entran en juego aquí lo que sí que
es cierto es que este texto
constitucional que cambiaría el estado
subsidiario de chile a un estado garante
de derechos sociales que introduciría
sin numerosas reformas que se declararía
a chile como un país plurinacional una
de las puntos más polémicos ecológicos
paritario muy a la vanguardia en muchos
temas no ha estado en el centro del
debate de los chilenos han sido muchas
otras más el contexto que el texto es o
que se ha debatido